foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn my
name is Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman's here
Holly Jolly Christmas oh happy holidays
Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah Ryan was
going around saying Happy Kwanzaa today
for some reason whatever you celebrate
I've got something for you it's a
mistletoe alert
well that's the gift I have for Ryan
today a big thanks to Alabama for
bringing in this I don't think it's
technically mistletoe so I guess you
don't have to kiss me those are the
rules it looks like Holly like uh
um yeah looks like the plant Holly I
don't even know her
Holly who we have a special gift for our
listeners today we decided to close our
studio for the holiday so we're
recording this in advance but the gift
we're going to give you is the gift of
community we've done this for the last
four months or so we called them Sundays
symposiums if you're listening to the
free public minimal edition of episode
372. you're gonna hear about a quarter
of that event it's Standalone you'll get
a ton of value from it we answer a bunch
of really thoughtful and important
questions from folks who are seeking
some answers and going through some
difficult times we see that with
Community though that's what community
does and TK pointed this out to me early
on there's something that we achieve
through these events that we've been
doing we called them Sunday symposiums
we're Gathering Sundays at noon in Los
Angeles with a small crowd of about 200
people and
we're just experiencing our time
together and each event is appreciably
different
but the thing that's the same there's a
lot of suffering tends to come to the
surface don't you think TK yeah that's
right man I mean there's no substitute
for like real-time contact connection
and conversation it's sort of like
having a meeting that we schedule versus
just being in the same place and talking
about what comes up and when you do that
with people there are so many
interesting things that come up things
that are worth celebrating things that
are worth analyzing things that are
worth comforting one another about and
uh it's just such a powerful experience
man if you haven't had a chance to do
this when we come back you got to join
us you really do yeah it's been it's
been awesome it's funny you bring up the
suffering um well not funny haha but it
just hit me like we're all suffering in
some way and what's nice about these
events is that
um man I almost look at it as like a
celebration of the suffering yes and a
lot of people yeah they think they're
alone in it and I think you know the
people who come to these events they
realize that they're not alone in the
suffering we're all suffering in some
way shape or form and we're just trying
to soothe that suffering a little bit if
you want to hear the whole event you can
find it over on patreon just click the
link in the description or visit
patreon.com the minimalist it's a couple
hours long and by the way we release all
of our Live Events over on patreon as
well for our true fans here but this
one's going out to all of our patreon
subscribers it's a big thank you it's
our Christmas gift to you shout out to
our entire Team Jordan for filming it
we have Professor Sean who did the audio
podcast Sean and post-production Peter
who took care of it made it sound and
look beautiful for you Danny of course
put together all the tick tocks and
Mallory did everything else
thank you what would we do without these
folks yes indeed so enjoy this special
gift we call it Sunday Symposium and if
you want to come to a future one just
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com we'll let you know when
the next one is appreciate you happy
holidays Merry Christmas cheers
howdy what's your name
hi my name is Nicole and this is my
third Symposium so awesome thank you for
doing this
um so as we approach the end of the year
it's pretty inevitable to look back and
think about what we accomplished
frustrations or even things that we wish
we would have done differently so how
can you
um let go of some of that guilt and
shame and beating ourselves up
comparing you know ourselves to what we
wanted to accomplish throughout the year
and this is what I was talking about in
the essay we are so addicted to
sort of
prescriptions right how do I let go
and letting go is not something you do
right
if I were to hand you this microphone
right now
and I said how do you let go of it what
would you do
I have no idea oh the microphone I'll
just give us something else oh okay
that's one way to do it
that's actually great that's not what I
was thinking right and that's my point
is I I can't give you seven steps to let
go of the microphone
the only way to let go of the microphone
you know intuitively I'll give it to
someone else I just drop it whatever it
is right if you found out that
microphone in your hand was a snake
would you ask me how do I let this go no
no of course not you would drop it
immediately
and the reason you would drop it is
because you have all the information you
need to stop clinging at that moment you
thought it was one thing but now it's
another thing isn't that the same thing
with the the regrets of the last year
the triumphs of the last year as well we
we want to let those go also it's not
just about
letting go of the things that are
unpleasant to us but by letting go of
the things that are even Pleasant to us
allows us more room for the things that
continue to be pleasant for us right and
so
you don't need to know how to let go as
soon as you see the thing
that you want to let go of you just have
to stop clinging to it that's all yeah
yeah I I uh I personally struggle with
like beating myself up over past
mistakes
and regrets and uh
you know I I think I probably
I think I do it more than probably
others do or maybe not maybe that's just
in my head but you know the other night
you go yeah yeah I'm better at
regretting it right
if you could go
and I start to
always like go over all the embarrassing
moments of my life and all the regrets I
don't know why I do this when I can't
sleep because it just helps me not sleep
more but like that's where my brain goes
same here yeah so yeah I can totally
relate to this and I'm sitting there and
I'm like
why do I beat myself up like I am like
these are all things that I've
apologized for that I've been forgiven
for that I moved past like why am I
bringing myself back to this this state
of guilt
and
I I said to myself well you must you
must like it
and I'm like what that's what no there's
no way I like it like that's so stupid
and I was like well dude you come here
quite often
you come back for a reason
and what I realized is that for me
uh my guilt uh it is sanctimonious like
I look at it as a virtue
and I think it has something to do with
when I was a kid being raised as one of
Jehovah's Witnesses like they teach you
basically the more guilty you feel the
more sorry that you are
the more in favor of God you are
so it was it was huge for me and um I'll
tell you like now when I start to feel
guilty about stuff
I have to ask myself like why am I
putting myself through this because
ultimately the best way to stop feeling
guilty is well to stop doing things that
make you feel guilty
I forget the name of it but um there's a
horror film
where
it's Freddy versus Jason
Child's Play Three no no that's not it
where the the guy is is being haunted by
this ghost and uh it's it's freaking him
out and he's changed houses he's tried
to address this problem in every way
possible and one day he decides to see a
therapist about it and
the therapist says have you ever stopped
to ask the ghost
why It's haunting
and it's like wait a minute okay if this
ghost wanted to kill me he would have
already done so he's followed me from
house to house I probably can't escape
him I've tried everything else so
instead of trying to get rid of the
ghosts maybe I should confront The Ghost
and say what the hell do you want from
me
and see what's there I think the best
way to let something go is to figure out
what aspects of that thing are worth
holding on to and when you figure that
out you're able to take what's useful
from it own it and embrace it and then
let go of what remains because you're
not letting go of something that you
need if something's bothering you from
your past you feel like you made a
mistake you feel like you had a failure
you're not supposed to just push that
away you're not supposed to just
suppress that you're not supposed to
just make yourself forget about it or
pretend like it didn't happen you're
supposed to wrestle with that you're
supposed to sort that out you're
supposed to be present with that and say
what the hell are you trying to teach me
ghost you're haunting me for a reason
I've tried everything I can to get rid
of you what are you trying to teach me
and we may find something
some kernel of truth about ourselves and
about what we value and about what we
care about or what we need to own up to
from those failures and when you can
take that and own it and say okay
then the ghost will stop haunting you
and it'll let you go and you won't have
to let it go so I would say don't try to
push past those failures and those
regrets visit them sit with them and let
those regrets be your teacher because
there's some aspect of that that you
need to hold on to because it's going to
serve you well in the future that you
want to create
yeah I've been working really hard to
like make friends with my guilt with my
anxiety with my stress
um yeah because I'm so good at just like
shoving it in a corner but yeah sitting
with it is it's a much more powerful
approach for sure
we got a question up here in the in the
front row also in the front row is our
good friend a very talented filmmaker
Jordan no more let's give him a round of
applause
Holly what's your name hi Rachel hey
Rachel I was going to test TK on that
but
[Music]
Show game gave me the The Walking book
as my gift to moving to California oh
yeah yeah so big shout out thank you
Rachel I hope it's valuable to you
um so I wrote out my statement slash
question
um so I wouldn't screw it up and then I
showed my new friend and he's like well
that's way too long so I
I so so I'm gonna try to turn it down
um I first wanted to thank you for
hosting these events and for all you do
to add value to my life and and others I
apparently lived under a rock for uh 47
years because I only discovered you two
years ago
so it's very bad my question
um the New Year's upon us I will not ask
you a resolution question
um what guidance would you give about
what we can do starting today to re-look
at what we are currently
doing when it comes to minimalism to
improve our processes without becoming
compulsive
I'm gonna
take a sharp right turn
you don't need to improve anything
it's one of the greatest lies that
you've been told is you need to improve
yourself you need to improve your things
you need to improve your house you need
to improve your situation okay sure
there are times where we fall down into
a crater we go into debt because we've
made some poor decisions I know I've
certainly made a lot of poor decisions
and got into a lot of debt and so
improving in that sense doesn't actually
mean improving yourself it means getting
out of the situation in which you've
already put yourself in right
and so
advertisers do a really good job of
teaching you that you need to improve
yourself that you are incomplete
that you are less than
that you are
not your best self right
maybe you're not your best self but it's
only because of the other essay I was
reading earlier about subtraction
our best self gets covered up by all of
these distractions accoutrements
material possessions expectations toxic
relationships things that make us lesser
than our ideal self and so it's not
about doing anything or acquiring
anything to become that best self it's
about subtracting everything that's
cluttering our lives in the first place
you know I'm I'm with that I I wouldn't
I wouldn't go into my new year with the
assumption that improving my life ought
to be my number one priority instead I
would focus on how am I already kicking
ass you know what am I already doing
well it's it's so interesting because
with a lot of my high school students
the hardest thing I'll ever ask them to
do is to make a list of like 10 things
they've done in the past year that
they're proud of and everyone gets stuck
at one we're so bad at thinking about
things that we do well and we're just so
amazing at critiquing ourselves and
evaluating ourselves but here's the
interesting thing you can't get better
unless you build on a foundation of
what's already worth working with right
how can you get anywhere useful in life
unless you say okay I found a starting
point upon which to build and this
starting point is worth working with so
in what way are you already worth
working with in what way have you
already built a foundation that's worth
building on like I would look back on my
year and say what did I do right what am
I proud of and what way am I kicking ass
what's something that I did that was
amazing that I like to keep doing and I
also add a little rule to it one of my
uh I had a boss name was sogi when I
used to work at Pappadeaux Seafood
Kitchen he had a no stories policy so
whenever you need is something no
stories you just tell them what you need
so you can't go hey it's soggy like uh
the man at table 66 he really didn't
like his shrimp and I need it no stories
what do you need I need a side of shrimp
for table 66. that's it I would say
doing no stories policy what you did
well so instead of saying like even
though my life was really crappy I did
manage to show up for my kids even
though I was tired all the time I did
manage to be nice towards other people
even though I didn't do it as much as I
wanted to I did manage to work on my
projects nope I worked my projects I
showed up for my kids treated my friends
with respect I took care of my health I
did this right I did this right and I
think that'll Orient you towards the
world in a way that just makes it easier
to keep doing to keep building on what's
already working
yeah
[Applause]
Josh I love what you tweet every January
1st
um it's uh it's day one or one day
you decide yeah
and uh you know there are things that
maybe we need to improve on health-wise
or
um whatever it is financially maybe we
got to pay off some of that
but you know if we can get clear on the
what
um I'm sorry on the on the why what
we're trying to work towards the what
kind of unfolds but you know you don't
need January 1st to start though I mean
it is nice to have start points don't
get me wrong but you can start today
um by the way you can only start today
you can't start tomorrow because when
tomorrow comes around it will be today
there is only now and it's the LIE we
tell ourselves we're going to start some
day as though that's a day of the week
right and
then someday arrives
and we put it off and Ryan has this uh
great joke that he said he's gonna make
his Twitter bio uh I'll put that on my
to-do list tomorrow
and that's quite often what we do
especially with New Year's resolutions
or it doesn't have to be New Year's any
other time I'll begin that on the first
of the month or I'll begin it next week
I also know someone isn't serious about
making some sort of change in their life
and is this isn't a judgment I don't
care what changes you make if you don't
want to make it please don't make it
but
a serious person takes now as the
opportunity for the change a serious
person and it's by the way it's not good
or bad to be serious but a serious
person recognizes that now is literally
the only time I can make a change
and I'll be future Nows but even the
past when you think about the past when
do you think about it right now
so the past exists but it exists in the
now and yes tomorrow will exist but in
the now and so any change you want to
make it's always going to happen right
now
Cali what's your name Laura hey Laura hi
nice to meet you you as well
so I have a question about family
relationships okay broken family
relationships that maybe are a priori is
to fix in this coming new year
and relationships are two-way streets
so I'm thinking I have a 16 year old son
16 and a half who lives with his dad
and we're kind of estranged but
um I put out breadcrumbs you know the
dad or the son or a
um the son okay yeah I have a good
relationship with the dad
so you know I keep throwing out like you
know crumbs but they don't really get
picked up and I want to give him the
freedom to pick up this relationship and
he's ready but if we're dealing with a a
mother or a sister or these kind of
uncomfortable family situations what is
your advice he I don't have any advice
but I I will tell you that
tips for relationships I have no tips
for you I have no how to's I have
nothing to prescribe I have no hope for
you
what about strategies
no no none of those either so
um I do have some insights and some
support there we go
let's lean on the these insights here
um
first off
he may never
be ready
I think we have to understand that first
because something happened that severed
the relationship at some point in time
and I'm not fault finding here that
actually does no good whatsoever right
um fault finding now you can see where
the the relationship bifurcated but it
probably bifurcated way before you
thought it did
and people often hang on to a
relationship you know there's examples
of
dead marriages right that well we're
still together we've been together for
30 years but the relationship's been
dead for 20.
or 25 or 29.
and so
we continue to hold on why is that I
just a moment ago I said I don't have
any hope for you a part of it has to do
with hope hope is one of the most
dangerous things that we have
because it says we have some expectation
about some future outcome and now I'm
tethering my
peace
my salvation my happiness to whatever
other thing is I'm hoping for right
that's one way to look at hope now
there's present moment hope of the
feeling of hopefulness that occurs right
now that has nothing to do with some
future outcome I'm all for that kind of
Hope right but for the
the kind of hope that is really just
goal setting but with a prettier name
that because that could become a prison
for you and the reason I say he may
never be ready
is you have to accept that first there
may be no hope in the relationship now
why do I say that it sounds really
demoralizing right like why the hell was
he telling her this
because as soon as we can accept that
what is that
acceptance is how we love to love
someone is to see them for who they are
without trying to change them manipulate
them persuade them coerce them to your
point of view right well what is that
that is acceptance
Things Are what the thing that TK would
say is like you know it's whatever God's
will is baby like someone from his
perspective I will make it a little more
Brian with nice on him oh yeah I would
say it was much uh deeper voice than it
but
um
Eckhart Tolle would say
it is as it is right that's what
acceptance is right now your
relationship is as it is right now and
if you need it to be any other way then
it won't be that other way but if you
make room for it to be another way
what you're basically saying is you've
dropped some breadcrumbs I get that
maybe the metaphor I would think of is
you've opened the door for him right and
he may not be ready for it right now but
you can keep that door open you can let
him know that that door is open because
anything else dragging him through the
door Kicking and Screaming will not get
you the result that you want
yeah the only thing I might add to that
that was beautiful like just leaving
that door open
um and you know hope Hope's a tool and
you got to be careful how you use it but
ultimately in a situation you know like
that
[Music]
um
any situation really like the more
compassion you can show someone
the more the more you show your support
and that will
um that will leave the door open yeah
yeah yeah
but he ultimately has to walk through it
absolutely in a relationship they have
to meet you halfway right yeah 100 okay
100 yeah
you mentioned that you have left out
breadcrumbs and he's not really picking
up on it
would you mind painting a picture for me
I like to know what does I've laid out
breadcrumbs look like for you yeah and
what does he's not picking up on it look
like for him
um well we live about 10 minutes away on
on the same street so maybe it'll be
like a really hot day right and I have a
pool at my place and I'll be like hey if
you if you want to come over for a swim
I can pick you up you know
thanks you know or um hey
you know if you want to come over for
dinner I'll I'll make you something
really yummy okay thanks
um
you know you want to go to a thing like
a movie right
no you know I don't want to go see a
movie so just you know I keep trying
different things now that said you know
he did come to Portland with me so it's
not totally closed off and we I think we
had a nice time but when I said hey
would you like to go to Portland again
next summer oh no you know I got X you
know all these excuses and I was like
okay cool so I'm trying to I'm trying to
keep the distance I'm okay because
um
I noticed that when we do make plans I
get a lot of anxiety around it and I
realize that I'm just re-traumatizing
myself so I'm like you know maybe I
should just give space to it
can I just butt in real quick because
you're making me think about
the timing of this he's 16 right yeah so
as teenagers we're better at Letting Go
than any other times in our lives
because there's a necessary attachment
you have when you're a baby you actually
need your parents right but somewhere
around puberty we start going through
this process of detaching and sometimes
it's rather destructive and we don't
realize what we're doing sometimes it's
something simple we're thumbing our nose
that our parents like oh that my parents
really want me to go to school for math
but I went there for philosophy haha mom
and dad take that
other times with me it's like you
accidentally set the house on fire
and and so
literally
um
but
what are we doing there we're showing
how independent we are I no longer need
you I'm no longer attached to you and as
a mother I understand that is the most
difficult thing right and that's why I
hear all the emotion in your voice
because there's a part of us
who want the other person's attachment
to us
remember I was dating someone once and I
explained to her like yeah I really like
this but I don't need this relationship
because I know you don't
I wish you just needed a little bit
right
and
by not needing it though it allowed me
to show up
as the best version of me because I
don't need to be here with this event
right now
I have a million other things I could be
doing I get to do this and so the next
time you get to do something with your
son not needing that attachment will
open it up for flourishing I love it
made me think about my relationship with
my godson man like there was just
something going on where I just was not
cool enough for this dude and whenever
I'd be like what's up man he'd be like
or I'd be like give me a pound man and
he'd be like what's that like oh man I
guess you know and and I I didn't
actually get close to him until I just
like made up my mind like I do not care
about this guy and so I like go sit next
to him and he say something to me I'd be
like I don't care about that and then it
would just starts to get really close so
some of that really does work
but you mentioned um
these communications are they usually
like taxed phone calls I'm just curious
sometimes yeah I'll text them and if I
don't hear back from them after
sometimes it'll be two hours or
sometimes four hours and if it's you
know if if it's plans I'm trying to make
I will call them yeah um but it's it's
both
both okay
all right so a couple of things
um one of the things I noticed about the
the pattern and the breadcrumbs is that
they all seem to be asked like pretty
pretty big ass like hey uh do you want
to hang out with me doing this
particular thing it seems like he's kind
of made it clear that for the most part
that's not something that he's
interested in doing I would recommend a
couple of things
um when making asks like that
I would perhaps make them so that no
response is necessary but if he wants to
be involved the door is open right so
hey going to pick up some food if you
want anything let me know no pressure
Done Right a couple of weeks later like
Hey FYI no it's hot outside if you ever
want to come by use the pool
ain't even gotta let me know no pressure
right that way if he doesn't reply it's
not a scandal for you or for him and
it's just letting him know that your
resources are available doing that every
once in a while you know kind of lets
him know hey we're good on my end right
and that's a cool thing to do as long as
it's not overdone but one thing I would
propose is maybe seeking to connect
over something that doesn't require him
to take a field trip with you how's it
going
you know hey how you doing
like maybe just show interest in him
like you don't have to go anywhere with
me we don't have to go get a cup of
coffee we don't have to go see a a movie
anything like that just curious how's it
going and give him the freedom to be as
quiet and non-detailed about that as he
wants to be it's you just putting the
feeler out there you're not forcing him
if he wants to talk he'll talk if he
doesn't want to talk that's okay too but
I think it's important to establish a
pattern of communication that says
connecting with me doesn't always have
to involve taking a field trip it could
just involve something small something
low cost like saying hello I I think
that might change the energy around it
but like Josh said you know continue to
be patient let them know that you're
there whatever you do don't get mad at
him for being who he is don't get to a
point where you're like you know what
I've offered you breakfast 50 times
forget it man I'm done because sometimes
we need someone to just persist without
being overbearing and letting us know
like hey
you can ignore me as much as you need
man I still got your back you know the
the contacts that you're holding with
that of I'm here for you when you need
it like I feel is apparent like that's
the best you can do yeah um Rob Bell uh
uh he's he's a I just look up to him as
as being a father
um I don't have any kids but you know
when Mariah and I finally have some kids
like I hope I can hold this context
which is uh his number one goal is to
enjoy his kids
so whenever he's you know through
through thick or thin he's holding that
context of like I just want to enjoy our
relationship and enjoy you as my child
and I think by doing that regardless of
the situation if that is coming through
I mean that's that's the best way you
can kind of keep holding that that door
open
um I love like the low barrier like just
hey you know whatever the pool's open
when you need it but
the one thing the one thing um I might
try it if you know this is an advice
it's just an observation
um have you ever tried asking him like
because clearly you want to provide
something for him yeah so I mean just
just asking Kim like is there anything
that you need oh yeah and if he says no
Then be like then that's great like if I
was having trouble buying Josh a
Christmas present right now December
25th is coming up
hey Josh what do you need for Christmas
nothing oh my God what a relief
[Laughter]
I want to bring a special guest onto the
stage real quick
to send you off with a message of Love
Can you welcome my nine-year-old
daughter Ella to this day
she would like to give you a little kind
loving
departing message what do you want to
say all
love people use things because the
opposite never works
thank you so much y'all we'll be back
out in a minute
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]